hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his essay
concrete approaches to investigating the
ontological mystery Gabriele Marcel is
going to begin by looking at something
that he thinks is particularly
characteristic of modern life but is an
ever-present problem or danger for human
beings because it's a possibility and
that is of reducing ourselves and what
it is that we do what we think what we
feel how we relate ourselves to others
how we understand ourselves to a matter
of what he calls functions and the word
in French is just merely functional it's
it's a cognate to our word function it
has really the same semantic range the
idea is that we reduced ourselves to our
roles or what it is that we're supposed
to do you might say in some cases our
job description and all the bullet
points underneath it those are what we
call functions and this is a very broad
term but there's there's a lot of
characteristics that functions are going
to have in common that we'll look at in
a moment now why does he begin with this
because he thinks that a world that has
been essentially reduced to or oriented
by what he calls the notion of function
is a very impoverished world a world in
which the people living in it don't even
realize how impoverished
their existence becomes and it blocks
the way to what he calls the ontological
mystery and our ontological need for
that so he says that I'm going to begin
with a sort of global and an intuitive
characterization of persons for whom any
sense of being or the ontological is
lacking and it's not like a you know
genetic defect or something like that
this is something that has been
prevented something that's been
corrupted something that's been taken
away from them he says more exactly who
have lost consciousness of having any
such dimension to their lives this is
the way he says most modern men and
women are and if a need for a sense of
being affects them at all it's in a
muted way as a vague uneasiness and he
talks about two things before we go on
that if they're worth bringing up here
he says that there are many people for
whom the ontological need has not been
entirely stamped out they haven't been
solely reduced to functions but the
problem is they can't articulate it they
live in an environment where anytime
that's something like that starts to
burst through its tamp down there's no
place for it to fit within that system
the other thing that's particularly
interesting and he brings this up twice
during this essay is that he's using the
term psychoanalysis but we could think
of any sort of analysis the person's
life using the resources of philosophy
he says that I wonder if a
psychoanalysis one more one deeper and
more nuanced than what has been
developed to date would not succeed in
revealing the morbid effects engendered
by the repression of this sense this
needs so unfortunately misunderstood so
he's not endorsing psychoanalysis he's
actually saying that much of the
psychoanalysis that we encounter is
about reducing people to their functions
so let's let's jump into that idea he
tells us that today's world is
characterized by an orientation
or if you want to look at the French
these orbits haseo literally making
things revolve around or orbit or you
know tie into the notion of function and
he says I'm using this word function in
it's generally accepted since it
includes vital functions social
functions he'll talk about psychological
functions in just a moment as well and
what does the world like that like he
says that one key feature of it is that
not not only as the individual treated
as if he or she is merely a aggregate or
a sort of nexus of their functions the
individual comes to perceive to feel to
think about him or herself precisely in
that way as an aggregate of functions
and if we pause here for just a moment
and think about how this comes to pass
from an early age within many of our
modern societies we are encouraged to
think of ourselves in terms of the
information that people have or produce
about us so in you know school we have
our grades and nowadays if you're a
parent you can go into the Parent Portal
or whatever it happens to be called for
your school and see whether your kids
are doing well on their assignments and
sometimes there's feedback and sometimes
there's not and there's this tendency
for for us to you know talk about people
as if they're this function or this set
of functions this is this is my child he
is a reflection of me right he's got an
a on the test what a smart kid not doing
so well in gym class captain of the
football team pick whatever you want
you know first clarinet in the band all
of these are things that they don't
there's nothing wrong with this but
they're not the the person him or
herself right and there's this tendency
to to view ourselves in terms of
our functions I'm a father I'm a
professor I'm a apartment dweller I'm a
person in front of this truck bored
shooting videos for you
all of these can become what it is that
we take ourselves as being and
particularly when we inhabit
environments where other people are
viewing things the same way and where
there's a lot of pressure to regard
yourself in that way where there's
practical effects if you don't if you
buck against that it's difficult to
resist that and and to not slip into
that it happens gradually so he talks
about functions let's come back to this
he says first of all there are the vital
functions it's hardly necessary to point
out the reductionist influence on the
concept of humanity it exercised by
historical materialism he's talking
about the entire Marxist tendency but we
could think of all sorts of other types
of historical materialism zazz well
modern economics that's non Marxian
treats people just as reductionistic
alee as any Marxist might have as a
historical materialist reducing you down
to the consumer that you are is is that
way right or Freudian theories he talks
about on the other and we might talk
about other things modern neuroscience
cognitive behavior therapy there are
tendencies to similarily reduce the
vital functions down to some sort of you
know manageable theory right and he says
then there's social functions consumer
is a function right producer citizen and
we might run through all sorts of other
things in our own social media saturated
environment reproducer through sharing
you know that could be another example
of a function and all of these are
things that do describe what we we are
or what we do they're not false in that
sense but they're not the totality of it
and then he says between these there
should be at least theoretically a place
for psychological functions
in his own time he says very often these
psychological functions are interpreted
in either in terms of vital functions Oh
your brain chemistry is off let's give
you some chemicals and that'll Ryu no
realign that the functions that are out
of whack right now or you know make sure
that you eat plenty of fish oil for your
brain so that you feel creative right
have some some beer at the time that you
want to be creative and some coffee at
the time that you want to be productive
those are ways of reducing psychological
functions down to vital functions we can
think of the whole realm of sexuality in
that way as well all the manuals about
how to do this sort of technique or that
sort of technique ignoring the fact that
it's really important for partners who
want to have intimacy to actually you
know be on a page other than manual
manipulation of the parts of the body
right he also says that that quite often
these psychological functions are
interpreted in terms of social functions
he says their autonomy and psychological
functions become precarious their
specificity is contested and then he
goes on and he says something really
interesting he's looking at this phrase
and following it up as if it's sort of a
leading clue about what is really going
on he says let's look at this notion of
the use of one's own time this is even
more applicable in our own presence when
we constantly have everywhere you go
not only evidence of what time it is or
what time is being taken in the form of
digital readouts but where our lives are
also permeated by so many other things
that are divided up into hours half
hours quarter hours seconds minutes
things along those lines you know you
might think about your calendar as you
use it if you do in fact have a date
planner or I use Google Calendar for
that it's sending me alerts all the time
it's parceling out what is my
if I go and sit in a waiting area
there's guaranteed to be some stupid TV
show on because everybody's got
televisions and they tune in to the
lowest common denominator Drac
and those will be talking about things
at the top of the hour and the half hour
that is all a matter of
functionalisation as Marcel is is
talking about it and he goes on and he
he discusses this notion of the use of
one's time precise amounts of time are
allotted for various function sleep is a
function one that must be carried out if
other functions are to be formed
properly right you get the the right
amount of sleep okay eight hours for you
nine hours for you five hours for you
maybe you're a little manic right she
also says that we dole these out for the
right amount of relaxation the right
amount of exercise the right amount of
this and you think about the ways in
which people try to manage their time
and the ways in which their time is
managed by other people particularly in
our new economy where if you're a minute
late for something that you've got as a
gig people start getting all upset how
is that the case well they know what
time it is
and they expect your time to be used in
that way he says we can imagine a
healthcare specialist prescribing a
person needs so many hours of recreation
per week it's simply a psycho organic
function that can no more be neglected
than the sexual functions for example
and he says no need to elaborate further
this sketches the picture the one thing
that he says is essential to this is
that there is a schedule so
functionalisation and schedules go hand
in hand what are the effects of this he
discusses how this ends up changing us
affecting us reducing us in some way he
talks about moments of disorder or
rupture and he says these are going to
occur accident sickness and what happens
then something like a tune-up
you get brought in and there's some sort
of regulation we're not going to have
this happen again we're going to make
sure that you follow this routine just
so you can make sure that you're
continuing on as this sort of person
this sort of person this sort of person
you know think about how when you fire
somebody these days in so many places
you have to have a plan in place that
you know brings to their attention what
it is that they did and then they have
to you know say how they're going to
change their behavior and then you you
know check it every so often a lot of
times these are actually fudged all
right but this is an example of what
Marcel is talking about he says that
from this point of view you know a
person is is is treated as the sort of a
machine and he says when it comes to
death from this objective and functional
point of view it appears only as ceasing
to function falling into total
uselessness becoming sheer waste to be
discarded there's no longer any real
meaning to death people move on or they
observe the proper rituals and those are
functionalized as well great example of
this is of course the funeral industry
where they put on you know fake smiles
in order to sell you very expensive
accoutrements like caskets and urns and
you know you have to go into their
stylized parlor that that stinks flowers
and dry-cleaning and then you know
follow the rituals and everybody must
speak in hushed tones those are actually
functions you can do that you can walk
that walk without giving a you know a
care about what you're actually doing
you can compartmentalize in that way
it's it's quite possible and many people
do that
this ceasing the function thing is is
quite important he says it doesn't just
have to be death consider the
heartbreaking image of a person who has
been retired why why what's wrong with
retirement well for a lot of
people retirement means the loss of
their meaning as a person this is why so
many people soon after they retire not
only disappear but die or languish it's
possible to do quite otherwise isn't it
but for people who have been so tied up
in their work
retirement becomes a sort of small and
long lingering death they're also cut
off from the people who they would
normally interact with for the most part
what do this produces he says is a world
that is empty a world that is Hollow it
says a world such as this is a sad
spectacle not only for the one who
observes it there's also the unspoken
and intolerable uneasiness felt by those
who see themselves reduced to living as
if they were nothing more than their
functions why would they be uneasy
because as soon as your functions go
away you go away there is no know you
apart from your functions if you view
things this way and that will induce an
uneasiness or anxiety so it's an empty
hollow world a little bit later in the
essay he talks about this as a world of
despair why he says that the world of
functions is a world of despair such
betrayal it seems as counseled if not
imposed by the very structure of a
functionalized world the functionalized
world is not a neutral environment that
we can either take or leave it imposes
itself upon us and you know you could
say that it's it's an entire set of
risks existential risks he goes on and
he says a few other things about this
that are particularly important a little
bit later on he talks about the
relationship between function and
problems and he says that the world of
the functions is a world that is filled
or literally you know full of packed to
the gills with problems not mysteries
there's no room for something going
beyond that now a problem is something
that can be formalized something that
can be set out it could be a problem
that's theoretical it could be a problem
that's practical but it's something that
can be dealt with by what what Marcel is
calling techniques or the earlier
translation of this was technics so
think about technology think about
disciplinary knowledge think about
bureaucratic ways of doing things think
about all the different ways in which we
find a mode to solve a problem and to
keep on solving that problem over and
over again those are what he's calling
techniques so it's it's a world that is
filled with with problems he goes on and
he tells us about techniques the world
of the problematical is is the world
where techniques of whatever kind
reigned supreme
there is no technique that is not or
could not be put directly at the service
of a given desire or given fear and
conversely every desire and every fear
will tend to create techniques geared
towards its own end desire and fear are
intimately connected with the
problematic and those aren't those
aren't bad emotions to feel or bad F
activities to have but the person who
lives primarily in terms of functions
and in terms of problems is going to be
motivated primarily by desire and fear
and the other emotions will in fact be
either breaks from that or just other
modes of those there are ways in which a
person can be happy but their happiness
is not really joy it's really just a
mode of desire or it's a shaky kind of
happiness that really reflects fear
underneath and a technique is helping
them coast along for the time being he
tells us that humans are capable of what
their technical abilities can accomplish
but at the same time we cannot recognize
that technical achievements are unable
to save us from ourselves and even
appear susceptible to conclude the most
sinister alliances with the enemy that
each one of us carries within ourselves
he talks about being taken over by
techniques and think about somebody who
found for example that downloading an
app and following its dictates and you
know entering the little data helped
their life improve in some way perhaps
to lose weight or to become more
productive or to start sleeping on a
regular schedule
and now they start applying that
mentality to everything why can't I
apply this to my dating there's apps for
that I could track everybody instead of
carrying a little black book which by
the way itself the old-school little
black book is just a set of techniques
as well isn't it or an apparatus for
techniques on seduction well I can carry
that on my phone why do I need to do
anything on my own I can find an app to
guide me along to nudge me well that's
that's turning things into techniques
and turning things into problems that
might indeed be mysteries when it comes
to weight loss for example it's quite
often important to figure out why a
person remains at the weight that they
do there are so many people who are
heavy so that they can be for example
invisible right or because they didn't
deal with the trauma or something like
that that's not the same thing as a
problem that can be solved that in is
more like what Marcel is calling a
mystery that would require a more
personal type of reflection and
intervention he also does tell us and
this is a back to the earlier part that
the world of techniques and the world of
functions is also what he calls the
world of the purely natural he says that
this world is saturated with problems
for the moment I want to point out that
to eliminate or try to eliminate mystery
is in the functionalized world we
describe to apply to events that rupture
the course of human existence
earth law of death the psychological and
pseudo-scientific category of the purely
natural he says this category is the
vestige or shadow of a degenerate
rationalism in which the cause accounts
for the effect that is totally explains
it so when we try to say things are
purely natural we often don't have a
clear sense of what that means other
than the fact that well if it is natural
I should be able to apply the sciences
or technology or some sort of discipline
to it and organize it and categorize it
so what Marcel is sketching out for us
here is not just a small problem a
little failure that goes on this is one
of the possibilities for the modern
condition and it's something that we we
have to stay on guard against and we can
only do that when we are able to reflect
on what's missing here in the world of
functions
you